while thousands of people have lost
their lives in ukraine millions of
millions have fled cbs evening news
anchor and managing editor that's nora
o'donnell has been speaking with some of
the people who have been forced from
their homes nora joins us now she's from
the poll she's at the poland ukraine
border nora good morning to you i can't
wait to hear what you've seen
yeah good morning to you well president
zielinski of course warning just that
this world this conflict has ended a new
stage of terror that's going to mean
that more people are going to be coming
across the border here and as war inches
closer here to poland they're expecting
more ukrainians
many of the people we saw they're tired
they're scared many of them they just
want to go back home but you know what
we've also seen is just how many polish
people are not just opening their houses
but their hearts we met a 75 year old
polish woman named barbara who's giving
up her bedroom so a ukrainian mother and
her children can stay together and then
she's sleeping on this teeny small couch
in her living room i also spoke with the
mayor of warsaw yesterday i mean that
city alone has taken in more than 300
thousand refugees that means the
population of warsaw is up nearly 20
percent in just two weeks the mayor
saying they can't handle the millions
more that are expected to come here into
poland
what worries you most when you talk to
the refugees some of the stories are
just overwhelming and incredible
especially about kids being killed you
know
and other kids watching it we try
everything we can you know to to create
a safe haven for them because we're
absolutely certain that you know the
ukrainians are also fighting for our own
security not only of poland but of the
western world the west has to wake up
and send a strong signal that they all
welcome not only in poland and romania
and slovakia but everywhere
you hear that the world has to wake up
that's the message not only from the
mayor but many of the people we met
including a mother who'd just gotten off
a bus with carrying her baby she hadn't
slept in two days gail i mean from
trains to buses i mean people just
almost had this blank stare in their
face they have gone through so much we
also met a family of five yesterday they
had their two dogs with them they were
staying in a shelter in warsaw they are
hoping that they can go to canada or the
united states but they're waiting for
their young daughter to recover from a
stomach bug it just for so many of these
people it just seems
the most dire and terrific situation as
they um terrible situation is they try
and find some way out gail
yeah i bet many of them are still in a
state of shock nora we thank you that's
why it's so important that you're there
so the world can wake up and see these
stories